now you queen of southern entertaining
in my opinion No thank you darling
you're writing a book on the subject yes
I mean there are a million etiquette
entertaining books out there so I'm
gonna do something different I'm gonna
make it fun and I'm going to let
everybody know all the little tricks
that they can employ and make it amusing
and fun and interesting and not to take
it seriously right all your parties have
a fun theme like you're the Flamingo
party and the alligator dinner party and
there's another dinner party coming up
where I have my own little touch added
you'll just have to wait
Patricius parties are always over the
top and they are just perfectly executed
I don't know how she does it well
actually I do know how she does it she
has other people do it if you had three
simple tips for someone maybe throwing
their first party what would those be be
totally organized and do everything you
can do ahead of time have somebody else
cook the food and have a margarita
machine ah that is my great tip because
if you have a margarita machine and you
start off with two or three margaritas
it doesn't make any difference but you
sir